(whizzing)
(door hinge)
- Warm days, am I right?
- Oh, you're tellin' me.
Ey, how's the old lady, huh?
- Ey, which one? My wife or my neighbor?
- Ahh!
- Ey you know, so what about yourself?
- Met this nice little
waitress down at the Denny's.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Her name's Maria.
- You gotta be careful
Becky doesn't find out.
- Oh, no, Becky doesn't know a thing.
(phone vibrating)
Hold on, I'm gettin' a phone call here.
- Okay.
(clears throat)
Hello?
Free dozen roses, you say?
Yo, Jeff. This company's
sayin' they wanna give me
a free dozen roses to
send to anyone I want.
All I have to do is give 'em a first name.
How 'bout that waitress down at Denny's?
- I hate to break it to
you, sounds like a scam.
I think you're on a radio show, buddy.
- I'm sorry, radio show?
- You know, a radio show
where a wife calls in
suspecting a husband's cheating.
Then they call him up,
offer him a dozen roses.
If he picks his side chick over her,
they call him out on it.
Dude, I think you're gettin' set up.
- Yeah, Jeff. All they
need is a first name.
No last name, no street address,
no billin' info, nothin'.
They'll find her on their own.
How crazy is that?
- You're tellin' me some flower business
is gonna be able to track down
a woman by her first name?
What is this? The CIA?
- You know the technology these
days and Twitter, who knows?
- I don't know, I'mma just
tell you one more time,
I think you're on a morning radio show.
- Listen Jeff, I'm not on a radio show.
- [Radio] "Listen Jeff,
I'm not on a radio show."
- I mean, what else do you want?
- I.. I think that's a coincidence.
- [Radio] I think that's a coincidence.
- Ey, listen Jeff. Can
you turn that down Jeff?
That's kinda echoing here.
They just upped it to 53 roses, Jeff.
How could I turn down the deal, huh?
- I'm gonna tell you right now.
You are 100% definitely
on a radio show right now.
- You've been listenin' to too much radio.
I shoulda never given you
that thing for Christmas.
- You know what?
If you actually think you're
gonna get away with it,
go for it.
- Yeah, I do. I do. You know what Jeff?
I'm gonna tell her a name,
and the name is Maria.
And I want you to include a note,
"Ey, baby. Miss ya, can't
wait to see ya this weekend."
Becky, how'd you get on the line?
- I told you how she got on the line.
- Oh my God, this is a radio show.
- I told you you were on a radio show.
I'll let ya know right now.
You just can't, you
can't trust those things.
It's too good, it's too good to be true.
(phone buzzing)
- Oh, hold on, gettin' a phone call.
Hello? Wow.
I just got offered a free cruise.
All I have to say is if I'mma
take my wife or my neighbor.
- Pfft.
- Yeah, I think her name's Carol.
(upbeat dance music)
(whizzing)
(door hinge)